should we rank herself should we just
like close our eyes and like scoot to
where we think we should be
how are we not going to bump into each
other did anyone take this into
consideration
sorry
[Music]
can we say like what we do we're like
whatever you are
so i'm a dancer i'm very physical i use
my body a lot i love bacon cakes i
always just like shove baked goods on my
friends
i teach acting to young kids i do mostly
musical theater oh my god because i'm a
weenie i know
um but i'm single as all heck hey i
am a journalism major i'm also a student
i'm double majoring in
psychology and criminal justice i'm also
an actress
i love to travel i've been to india five
times
okay so we have to do this should we
rank herself should we just like close
our eyes and like scoot to where we
think we should be
yeah you know what i mean just go for it
on an individual basis i think that's
very smart
i feel like my personality is really
attractive my looks
i feel like i'm like okay like i don't
think anyone would look at me and be
like
oh i'm nervous how are we not going to
bump into each other did anyone take
this into consideration
sorry we're all so humble we're like
we're all fine let me know
what if you don't know like which one is
the number
see i saw him on some more as a two but
i didn't know where y'all were standing
oh my gosh then put yourself at him the
girl who i found most attractive was
jordan
she has a great personality and she's
confident dope
oh see i thought this is
[Music]
true
[Laughter]
how would we do it off with like
immediate first impression and
attraction to the person
i'm just gonna put it out there just
saying just so we do it one two three
four
oh sorry one
two three four one two three
four got it um one two three four
okay uh one two three four
okay i'll be two because i got all four
twos okay i think i got three four the
most so i'll
stick in that window depending on the
other person's there were attributes
that i saw on the other girls that i
didn't see
myself and hence i would have put them
higher as well over me
so people like she's so sweet she's so
funny she look
but like i wouldn't date her i guess
i'll be one
okay okay cool beans i already like
so much dearly and i would date all of
you so does that make me a three
okay yeah i'll just stay here yeah
nobody really wanted to be last and i
could kind of
feel that vibe so i was just like you
know it's fine
like nobody is a five really
i don't think so but i mean
where do you think you would fit
yourself in this one then uh well i mean
i don't know because i feel like
personality is a big thing
yeah yeah she's almost oh by far two two
three thanks
see i would say three and then the same
four three not saying you don't have a
personality but i'm like
oh i'm five again i think we just put
ourselves in order of most extroverted
not the most personality
this is final
can you put on
[Music]
[Music]
do you want to start did you go
over there and then like just shift down
i think michelle was the most attractive
how she looked how she carried herself
and it just seems like
someone that's going to live an exciting
life i guess you could say or that you
could have like a deep conversation with
could you switch with her
[Music]
i forgot they can't even hear me
okay what would you switch i switch her
and her
you go over there
[Laughter]
personally for me she kind of looks like
kristen bell
and i i really like kristen bell so i
probably put her in
on the one or two position and i kind of
like her vibe
i think her whole aesthetic is very nice
so
for me it's either one or two up here i
think that maria was the most attractive
for me
it was just like her whole vibe and like
i liked how her hair was how her makeup
was done like she looked very nice
are we content with five being five i'm
not where do you currently want five
i want her at least three five goes up
she should be a four because it's like
meeting the middle i think four is fine
five and four switch the
we're gonna get ripped the new one i
don't wanna get the pointer here guys
are not afraid to be more blunt they
were straight up
hey you're attractive you're attractive
you're not but girls were like
i don't wanna be rude you know we're all
beautiful in our own way
all right are we good we're good i'm
good we're locking in
cool god i was ruthless
i feel bad
the way the guys were ranking the girls
i actually think we were doing it mostly
by personality
i was super anxious about ranking them
my hands were getting all clammy i was
like
really uncomfortable being the one to be
like putting them where i thought
you know it's obviously something that
we do like in day-to-day life we rank
people
you know subconsciously but having to do
it like in front of them
and like them watching you rank them was
it wasn't fun but definitely a memorable
experience
well i was at five and now i'm here so
i'm like
thank you i don't know it's very
interesting i feel i did think coming
into this like cultural stereotypes
would be a factor
them making me first kind of shot that
down i guess because i didn't think they
would choose
like an asian girl first i think when i
think of a male
viewing me as attractive or not versus a
female it's definitely different
because in a male setting judging me i
knew that was gonna happen like i'm not
stupid so like i'm aware of
how others view me i was surprised
at them placing me at the bottom but at
the same time i know out of a room of
beautiful girls that i was put in
but from the jump there was there was no
chance for me i was
yeah there was no chance there me being
the only black girl like
i knew that i wouldn't really rank
because american beauty standards versus
what people see people of color
it's different the guys that i interact
with they socialize more with
black women and they think more black
women are attractive
i think that the guys ranked the woman
from appearance more than personality
do you usually feel like you're the most
attractive person
most of the time i feel like it just
confirms that attractiveness is so
subjective and circled and presented in
one way and always
has been even though i have my days
where i'm like oh
you're not really that cute in days
where i'm like oh you like
you you cute i would say
i wouldn't change i wouldn't change
he i feel like he he would give you
flowers time out
time i need to see them